alors on dit souvent que les colonies
c'est l'obstacle à la solution des deux
États mais je voudrais rappeler que avec
l'Égypte ça n'a pas empêché un accord de
paix Israël s'est retiré de tout le
Sinaï et à évacuer les colonies qui
étaient sur place également euh Israël
s'est retiré de l'entière euh territoire
de l'entier territoire de de de la bande
de Gaza où il y avait également des des
des colonies
et c'est justement on semble que ça sera
en pensant que voilà que si si les
ocolonist c'est un obstacle à la paix
alors maintenant qu'on qu'on qu'on les
retire de la bande de Gaza on on pour
avoir la paix vivre en bon voisinage or
ce qu'on ce qu'on a encontré c'est juste
le contraire donc euh la question des
colonies elle devra être résoue dans le
cadre des du processus de paix qui aura
lieu plus tard et Israël comme je dis
bien a déjà prouvé que le cas échéant en
échange d'une véritable paix durable
pourra euh éventuellement évacuer des
des colonies